hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game you guys suggested from
round eight of this year's Baku open so
the penultimate round it is uh
azerbaijani a woman Grandmaster Khan in
Bali versus Indian Grandmaster hashabara
takoti and as you can see there's quite
a bit of a rating difference going on
here uh but that will not stop kanim
from defeating a 2600 Grand Master in
only 16 moves so as you can imagine
something has gone terribly wrong or in
her case uh terribly right so let's see
now what this is all about like I said
this is round eight uh they're they're
both doing great in the tournament only
one loss each so far so whoever took
this one uh should go a long way
especially if you can finish on a high
note in the final round so let's see
what happened in the game we have Ponte
E4 by kanim and uh Harsha replies with
Ponta C5 he goes for the Sicilian
Defense and pawn to C3 the allop in
variation much like nepo played against
Maxim yesterday we have Pawn to D5 a
very principal decision because now uh
you don't have to worry about bringing
your queen into early into the game the
C3 square is already taken by the pawn
so you don't have to worry about wasting
Tempe with the queen so e captures Queen
captures and now Pawn to D4 and now
usually you'll see Knight to F6 here
Knight to C6 also E5 is very popular E6
is popular but here we have Pawn to G6
going for that early Bishop fianchetto
uh Knight to F3 and now Bishop to G7 we
have Knight A3 uh a very useful Square
for the Knight as you've seen in the
game nipple versus Maxime yesterday uh
probably going for for B5 or C4 or even
Bishop to C4 is possible in some lines
all depends on what black plays so here
Knight to H6 and and now Bishop C4 can
be played and it's not a bad move but
then Queen to E4 check comes in you kind
of have to trade queens and it kind of
takes the excitement out of the position
so she tries something uh different she
plays D captures in C5 which basically
says okay we trade queens and then we
play uh variation will go something like
Queen characters with checking captors
Knight G4 goes after the F2 Pawn but
then you go Bishop to B5 with check
Knight to D7 and you can even play Rook
D1 and it's a very nice game for both
white and black uh point being that if
you capture on F2 which of course is
possible then even King E2 lets ignite
the G4 and then Rook the D1 and black
will have trouble developing here so
that's kind of the idea but in the game
he played uh Queen characters in C5 he
kept the Queens on the board and now
Bishop to E3 she attacks the queen we
have Queen to A5 and now there is a game
where Bishop to B5 check was played but
here we have Knights the B5 and it is
now as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how
Harsha reacts to this he plays Bishop to
D7 and this is not the best way to do
this the problem is uh if you go for
something like Knight to D7 which is
kinda what you should do then uh you've
secured the d8 square then B4 doesn't
really do all that much the problem is
if you play something like castles uh B4
is uh well just life changing for white
is now the the the the black queen has
doesn't have a good square and you can't
really lose control of the C7 Square
then the rook and A8 will hang so here
you kind of have to go back and then
after you trade Queens you no longer
control C7 and then the Rook will hang
you don't want to play this right away
first you want to capture here captures
capture send the Knight to C7 but uh
yeah The Rook on A8 will suffer so
that's uh that's the idea uh but in the
game Bishop to D7 was played and this
allows this very tricky Queen to D5 move
and the idea is that the queen on A5 is
undefended so imagine an oh sorry
imagine a knight to D6 check here the
queen will just be lost uh so how do you
continue here uh there are a couple of
moves you could play for example castles
is one such move because now the king is
not in range of the Knight but then you
have to give up the B7 Pawn but this is
maybe the best uh harsher had and here
you have to sort of go Bishop to C6
Queen to C7 you offer a queen trade so
that's how you save the Knight and after
the queen moves you move the Knight and
everything is perfectly fine the game
continues white will be a little bit
better however he wanted to defend
everything he played Knight to C6
defense the pawn defends the queen but
now comes Bishop captures on H6 she uh
definitely played this with with engine
like Precision Bishop captures an H6 and
now Knights the E5 again uh taking
control of the entire board making sure
Knight captures on E5 is impossible
because the queen on A5 would again hang
if Knight captures then just Knight the
D6 check picks up the queen here so
instead we have Castle's King side here
and you might be thinking but why not
Castle's Queen side so we defend the
bishop isn't that better uh well you
kind of could play this uh but then
again you lose the queen Knight captures
on C6 attacks the queen and the Rook
here and after you recapture still
Knight the D6 check will pick up the
queen but okay black will get counter
play let's say Rook captures Queen
captures Queen now you do get Bishop to
D2 chicken after King to D2 let's say
you double up on the D file and this
looks very scary okay the two Rooks are
here the bishop Perry is here uh you
know the bishop pair ended the Rook pair
working together but after something
like F3 it seems that the white king
will be safe You're Gonna Get Your Best
Shot into the game you're gonna get the
Rooks into the game
and the white Position will be better uh
in the long run so instead he went for
Castle here he said all right I'm gonna
give back material now just to survive
uh uh maybe I can survive this but now
comes Knight captures on D7 Rook ate the
d8 pinning the Knight now and Rook to D1
and here we have Knights the B8 and now
there is only one moved um uh win this
game but that's not the move I'm
interested uh in for you guys to find uh
but okay you can you can even try it
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for white while I give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on achieving this
even though I tried to trick you a
little bit by saying I'm not interested
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show of course the movie
spawned to be for that that is the
winning move as it often is as uh here
there's really no good Square for the
queen uh the problem is uh how how do
you play now uh you can move the queen
to A4 you can move the queen to A6
that's pretty much it you don't have
other squares uh the problem is if you
play Queen the A4 which uh keeps the
queen in the game uh but not for long
night the C5 happens attacks the queen
and also attacks the rook and the eight
and now you really are a good options
once you move the queen or your trade
doesn't really matter let's say move the
queen queen capture Sandy if you even
give up the queen Rook captures Queen
captures with check and down after King
to G7 uh you don't want to uh move the
Rook away from the D file then Queen to
C1 check will be annoying so First
bishop to C4 and now okay you wanna
Captain C3 deliver a check so you play
A6 and remember this is if you know
assuming black would play the absolute
best moves now just Castle here and now
after eight characters on B5 there's a
bishop to B3 a nice Vision Two with an
attack on the queen queen characters and
only now you pick up the Knight here and
after all is said and done you have two
Rooks and the Knight for the queen and
of course this is very much winning for
white so instead after this B4 uh move
he didn't go Queen day for hasha played
Queen to A6 but now he runs into a
different trick that of course is Knight
cap for some B8 and he was in this
position animal 16 at that resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here the problem is uh well there
are a couple of moves you could consider
like uh maybe capturing the queen and uh
on D5 but let's say you try this a rook
captures on D5 uh now comes Knight
captures on A6 and now after Rook
chapter 71 with checking captures even
Rook to d8 with Chuck King the C2 you
can even play Rook the D2 with checking
B3 and pick up the Knight on A6 white is
always up a piece at the end of the line
let's say Knight captures an A7 doesn't
really matter what you do Rook captures
Bishop capture so now you're up a piece
you're up a full night and also once
those pawns start marching forward
there's really no counter play here and
another thing after Knight captures some
beat okay you don't have to trade Queens
you could play Rogue captures on B8 but
then pretty much any mover you can play
and you're still up material Bishop B2
you castle and that's pretty much it
even if something like Rook after d8 you
can give up the queen for two rocks but
you don't even have to you can play
Queen to C4 and still it's very much
winning for white let's say Rook
captures on D1 uh Bishop capture Sandy
one now Rook to d8 it doesn't matter
just Bishop B3 black will have to waste
a move to defend this and after Pawn to
E6 just castles and you are up a full
piece of course this is completely
winning
so uh absolutely crushing game by uh
coming by and also a crushing tournament
here uh these are uh her standings after
eight runs you can see she started with
a very nice win against a very strong
Grand Master eager uh vladislav kovalev
and then a four draws against four grand
Masters uh then a loss against an
international Master Igor samonekov and
then uh two wins against two Indian
Grandmasters uh about a subramanian and
takoti so interestingly out of the uh
eight games that she played she did not
lose a single game against the Grand
Master she even defeated three of them
in Dragon's 4 but she loses the
Ukrainian International Master Igor
someone Echo so you know what are you
gonna do but there is still one more
game they're still round nine I believe
there are nine nine runs I don't want to
trick you guys so let me just check real
quickly
uh
yeah there are nine rounds which start
uh round nine starts tomorrow so we'll
see if she will be able to pick up a win
if she picks up a win then she will uh
definitely finish nicely she's currently
in number 13 in the tournament so with a
win in the final round could it will
definitely be in the top 10 just how far
uh we will uh we will have to see so
yeah a great game taking it down at 2600
Grand Master in 16 moves not a small
feat uh so hope you enjoyed that and
that I mean you have to know if you're a
sicilian player or if you play this
against the Sicilian quite a lot you
have to know the all up in variation uh
it can you know uh uh be deadly for
black and uh for white as you as you've
seen
how nipple played it against Maxima
Sheila grav yesterday uh yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank ravishing reptiles YouTube
Lord of Bones Amazon thank you for
videos and Dr Heisenberg for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of
everything that's happening in the Chess
World and uh well uh just checking up on
your wonderful suggestions as I usually
do so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day